Como saben, uno de los grandes placeres de viajar
y uno de los deleites de las investigaciones etnográficas
es la oportunidad de vivir entre aquellos
que no han olvidado el pasado...
que aún lo sienten en el viento...
lo tocan en las piedras pulidas por la lluvia...
lo sienten en el sabor amargo de las hojas de las plantas.
El simple hecho de saber que el chamán jaguar sigue viajando más allá de la Vía Láctea
o que aún se escucha con fuerza el eco de los mitos de los viejos inuit
o que en las montañas del Himalaya
los monjes budistas siguen aspirando a alcanzar el aliento del Dharma
todo esto nos recuerda la revelación principal de la antropología:
y esta es, la idea de que nuestro mundo, en el que vivimos,
no existe en un sentido absoluto
sino que no es más que un modelo de la realidad,
la consecuencia de un conjunto concreto de opciones adaptativas
que nuestros ancestros hicieron, con mayor o menor éxito, hace muchas generaciones.
Y por supuesto, compartimos los mismos pasos imperativos de la adaptación.
Todos nacemos. Traemos nuestros hijos al mundo.
Experimentamos ritos de iniciación.
Tenemos que afrontar la inevitable separación que provoca la muerte.
Y no debe sorprendernos que todos cantemos, bailemos,
y vivamos el arte.
Pero lo que es interesante es la cadencia de las canciones,
el ritmo del baile en cada cultura.
Ya sea los Penan en las selvas tropicales de Borneo,
o los acólitos del vudú en Haití,
o los guerreros en el desierto de Kaisut del norte de Kenia,
el curandero en las montañas de los Andes
o un caravansaray en las arenas del Sáhara.
Este, por cierto, es un amigo con el que viajé al desierto
hace un mes.
Un pastor de yaks de las laderas del Chomolungma,
el Everest, la diosa madre del mundo.
Todos estos pueblos nos enseñan que existen otras formas de ser,
otras formas de pensar,
otras formas de orientación en la Tierra.
Y si reflexionamos un poco sobre esta idea
solo puede llenarnos de esperanza.
Ahora, junto con las miles de culturas del mundo
forman un entramado espiritual y cultural
que abarca todo el planeta
y es tan fundamental para su bienestar
como el entramado biológico conocido como biosfera.
Y ustedes pueden pensar en llamar a este entramado de vida cultural biológico
como lo que es una “etnosfera”.
Y la etnosfera podría definirse como
la suma total de todos los pensamientos, sueños, mitos,
ideas, inspiraciones e intuiciones que han cobrado forma
gracias a la imaginación humana desde el principio de su conciencia.
La etnosfera es el gran legado de la humanidad.
Es el símbolo de todo lo que somos
y lo que podemos ser como especie sumamente curiosa.
Y de igual modo que la biosfera está sufriendo un grave proceso de erosión,
la etnosfera también padece este proceso,
a un ritmo incluso más rápido.
Ningún biólogo se animaría a decir
que el 50% de las especies o más han estado o están
al borde de la extinción porque simplemente no es cierto.
Y a pesar de esto, el escenario más apocalíptico
en el dominio de la diversidad biológica,
apenas se aproxima a lo que conocemos como el escenario más optimista
en el área de la diversidad cultural.
Y un gran indicador de esta situación es la pérdida de idiomas en el mundo.
Cuando nació cada uno de los presentes en esta sala
había 6000 idiomas hablados en el planeta.
Una lengua no es simplemente un conjunto de palabras
o reglas gramaticales.
Una lengua es un destello del espíritu humano,
el vehículo mediante el cual viene a nuestro mundo material
el alma de cada cultura particular.
Es una fuerza generadora de la mente,
un cauce, un pensamiento y un ecosistema de posibilidades espirituales.
Y de los 6000 idiomas, mientras estamos sentados aquí en Monterey,
más de la mitad ya no se susurrarán a los oídos de los niños.
Ya no se enseñan estos idiomas a los niños,
lo que significa efectivamente, excepto que algo cambie,
que estos idiomas están prácticamente muertos.
¿Qué podría ser más solitario que estar envuelto en el silencio,
ser el último hablante de tu propia lengua,
y no poder transmitir el conocimiento de los ancestros
o anticipar el futuro de los niños?
Y peor aún es el horrible destino de alguien
cada dos semanas, en un lugar del mundo,
porque cada quince días, fallece un anciano
que se lleva con él a la tumba
las últimas sílabas de una antigua lengua.
Y sé que algunos de ustedes consideran que quizá el mundo
sería un mejor lugar si todos habláramos la misma lengua
Y yo respondo: “¡Genial!"
Pero que este idioma sea el yoruba o sea el cantonés
o el kogi.
Entonces todos descubriríamos lo que sería
no poder hablar nuestro propio idioma.
Y por eso, lo que me gustaría hacer hoy
es algo así como llevarlos de paseo por la etnosfera.
Un breve paseo a través de la etnosfera
para darles una idea de lo que realmente se está perdiendo.
Ahora, muchos de nosotros solemos olvidar
que cuando digo "distintas realidades"
realmente quiero decir distintas realidades.
Tomemos por ejemplo, este niño de Barasana al noroeste del Amazonas,
el pueblo de la anaconda,
que creen, según su mitología, que vinieron de un río de Leche,
procedentes del Este, del vientre de las serpientes sagradas.
Estas son personas que cognitivamente no distinguen
el color azul del verde,
porque el dosel del cielo
se confunde con el bosque
del cual depende su existencia.
Tienen una curiosa costumbre lingüística matrimonial
denominada "exogamia lingüística":
deben casarse con alguien que hable otra lengua.
Y todo esto se debe al pasado mitológico
y lo curioso es que en cada choza comunitaria
donde se hablan hasta seis o siete idiomas
por la endogamia,
no se escucha a nadie practicando un idioma.
Simplemente escuchan hasta que un día empiezan a hablar.
O una de las tribus más fascinantes con las que he vivido
son los waorani que viven al noreste de Ecuador.
Un pueblo sorprendente con el que se tuvo un primer contacto pacíficamente, en 1958.
En 1957, cinco misioneros intentaron entrar en contacto
con ellos y cometieron un grave error.
Lanzaron desde el avión
fotos en las que aparecían ellos,
en actitud amistosa,
sin tener en cuenta que aquel pueblo de la selva tropical
jamás había visto un objeto bidimensional.
Recogieron las fotos del suelo de la selva,
las miraron por detrás de los rostros, buscando el resto de la forma o la figura
humana y al no encontrar nada, concluyeron que se trataba de “tarjetas de visita”
del diablo. Entonces mataron con sus lanzas a los cinco misioneros.
Pero los waorani no solo mataban con sus lanzas a los extranjeros.
Se mataban entre sí.
El 54% de la mortalidad del pueblo se debió a la matanza mutua.
Analizamos las genealogías hasta ocho generaciones anteriores
y encontramos dos instancias de muerte natural
y cuando insistimos a los habitantes para que nos contaran sobre eso
admitieron que uno de sus semejantes se había vuelto tan viejo
que murió por viejo: así que con sus lanzas lo mataron por viejo. (Risas)
Pero al mismo tiempo, tenían un conocimiento perspicaz
de la selva tropical que era sorprendente.
Sus cazadores podían oler la orina de los animales a 40 pasos
y podían decir de qué especie se trataba.
A comienzos de 1980, me dieron una misión realmente sorprendente
Un profesor de Harvard me preguntó
si me interesaría ir a Haití,
infiltrarme en las sociedades secretas,
que eran la base del poder de Duvalier
y los Tonton Macoutes,
y proteger el veneno utilizado para crear zombies.
Para entender lo que se me pedía,
tenía que conocer algo de esta notable religión:
el vudú. Y el vudú no es un culto de magia negra.
Por el contrario, es una compleja visión metafísica del mundo
Es interesante.
Si les pidiera que nombraran las grandes religiones del mundo
¿qué dirían?
cristianismo, islam, judaísmo, budismo, etc.
Siempre nos olvidamos de un continente, África
como asumiendo que los africanos del Sub-Sáhara
no tienen fe religiosa, aunque evidentemente sí la tienen.
El vudú es simplemente la síntesis
de estas profundas ideas religiosas
que surgieron durante la trágica diáspora en los tiempos de la esclavitud.
Pero, lo que hace al vudú tan apasionante
es que es una relación dinámica
entre los vivos y los muertos.
Los vivos dan origen a los espíritus.
Los espíritus se pueden invocar desde debajo del Gran Agua
respondiendo al ritmo de los bailes
para desplazar momentáneamente el alma de los vivos,
para que en ese breve pero brillante momento, el acólito se convierta en dios.
Por eso es que a los vudistas les gusta decir que
"Ustedes los blancos van a la iglesia y hablan de Dios.
Nosotros nos convertimos en Dios en el templo".
Y al estar poseídos, el espíritu los toma,
¿Cómo les haría daño?
Uno ve estas demostraciones sorprendentes:
acólitos del vudú en estado de trance
manipulando las brasas ardientes sin lastimarse,
un ejemplo asombroso de la capacidad de la mente
para dominar el cuerpo
cuando se cataliza en el estado de extrema excitación.
De todos los pueblos que he visitado,
los más extraordinarios son los kogi
de la Sierra Nevada de Santa Marta al norte de Colombia.
Son descendientes de la antigua civilización tairona,
que antaño se extendía por toda la costa caribeña colombiana.
Huyendo de los españoles de la conquista,
los kogi se refugiaron en un aislado macizo volcánico
que sobresale en la costa caribeña.
En un continente teñido de sangre por las conquistas
estas personas nunca fueron conquistadas por los españoles.
Hasta la actualidad conservan como sistema de gobierno el sacerdocio ritual.
El proceso de formación de los sacerdotes es extraordinario.
Los futuros sacerdotes son separados de sus familias
a los 3 ó 4 años de edad, y durante los 18 años
siguientes, viven sumidos en un mundo de tinieblas,
en chozas de piedra en la parte baja de los glaciares.
Dos periodos de nueve años
elegidos deliberadamente para imitar los nueve meses de gestación
que pasan en el vientre de su madre natural.
Metafóricamente se encuentran en el vientre de la gran madre.
Y durante todo este tiempo,
se les enseña los valores de su sociedad,
los valores que conservan la premisa de que sus oraciones
y solo sus oraciones mantienen el equilibrio cósmico...
o deberíamos decir ecológico.
Un día, al final de este increíble proceso de iniciación,
se les hace salir antes del amanecer
y por primera vez a los 18 años de edad,
ven salir el sol. En ese momento cristalino,
de la primera luz, mientras el sol comienza a bañar los desniveles
del bellísimo paisaje,
de repente, todo lo que habían aprendido de forma abstracta
se les aparece con todo su esplendor. El sacerdote que los ha formado da un paso atrás y
les dice: “¿Lo veis? Es tan bello como os había dicho.
Es hermoso y a vosotros os toca protegerlo”.
Se autodenominan “hermanos mayores”
y dicen que nosotros somos los hermanos menores
porque según ellos, somos los responsables estar destruyendo el mundo.
Este nivel de intuición es muy importante.
Cuando pensamos en los indígenas y el medio ambiente,
invocamos a Rousseau
y la vieja mentira de un salvaje aristocrático
lo cual es una idea racista en su simplicidad
o de forma alternativa, invocamos a Thoreau
y decimos que estas personas están más cerca de la Tierra que nosotros.
En realidad, los indígenas no son sentimentales
ni son débiles por la nostalgia.
No hay tiempo para ninguna de esas opciones
en los pantanos de Asmat infectados con malaria
o los congelados vientos del Tíbet, pero ellos tienen, sin embargo,
han forjado una mística tradicional de la Tierra a través del tiempo y rituales
que no se basa en la idea de ser conscientes de ello de forma cercana
sino en una intuición mucho más sutil:
la idea de que la Tierra misma solo puede existir
para ser asumida en el interior del ser por la conciencia humana.
¿Qué significa eso?
Significa que un niño originario de los Andes
que fue criado para creer que la montaña es un espíritu apu
que marcará su destino
será un ser humano totalmente diferente
y tendrá una relación diferente con ese recurso natural
o lugar que un niño de Montana
que cree que una montaña es una pila de rocas
lista para ser explotada.
Si esa montaña es el hogar de un espíritu o una pila de minerales es irrelevante.
Lo que es interesante es la metáfora que define la relación
entre el individuo y el mundo natural.
Yo crecí en los bosques de Columbia Británica
donde se creía que esos bosques existían para talarse.
Eso me hizo un ser humano diferente a
mis amigos, los kwakiutl,
que creen que esos bosques son el hogar de Hukuk
y los pájaros sagrados además de
los espíritus caníbales que habitaban la parte norte del mundo
con quienes debían comprometerse estas comunidades durante su iniciación Hamatsa.
Ahora, si comenzamos a pensar que
estas culturas pueden crear realidades diferentes,
podemos empezar a entender
algunos de sus extraordinarios descubrimientos. Tomemos esta planta.
Es una foto que tomé al noroeste del Amazonas en abril pasado.
Esta es la ayahuasca, muchos de ustedes pueden haber oído hablar de ella.
La preparación psicoactiva más poderosa
del repertorio de un chamán.
Lo que hace a la ayahuasca fascinante
no es el potencial farmacológico de esta preparación
sino la elaboración de la misma. Se hace de dos recursos diferentes.
Por un lado, está esta liana leñosa
que tiene una serie de betacarbolinas
harmina, harmolina, levemente alucinógena.
Inhalar esta sustancia
es como tener una nube gris azulada de humo
por la que pasa nuestra conciencia
pero se mezcla con las hojas de una planta de la familia del café
denominada Psychotria viridis.
Esta planta tiene triptaminas muy poderosas
muy parecidas a la cerotonina del cerebro, dimetiltriptamina-5
metoxidimetiltriptamina.
Si alguna vez han visto a los yanomami
aspirando esa sustancia por sus narices
esa sustancia fue creada de un conjunto de diversas especies
que también contienen metoxidimetiltriptamina.
Tener que inhalar ese polvo
es como salir disparado por el cañón de una escopeta
y al mismo estar inmerso en pinturas barrocas y aterrizar en un mar de electricidad. (Risas)
No crea la distorsión de la realidad
sino una disolución de ella.
En realidad, solía discutir con mi profesor Richard Evan Shultes
el hombre que inició la era psicodélica
con su descubrimiento de los hongos mágicos
en México en la década de 1930.
Yo solía argumentar que no podía clasificar estas triptaminas
como alucinógenos porque en el momento que uno está bajo sus efectos
no hay nadie mejor que uno para experimentar la alucinación. (Risas)
Pero el tema de las triptaminas es que no se pueden ingerir de forma oral
porque se desnaturalizan a través de una enzima
que se encuentra en el estómago humano denominada monoaminoácidos.
Solo se puede ingerir de forma oral en conjunto con
otros químicos que desnaturalicen los MAO o monoaminoácidos.
Ahora, lo fascinante de esto es que
los componentes químicos de esta liana
son precisamente los inhibidores MAO necesarios
para potenciar las triptaminas. Entonces, uno se pregunta:
¿Cómo pudo ser que en una flora de 80 000 especies de plantas,
estas personas encontraron 2 plantas morfológicamente no relacionadas,
que cuando se combinan de esta manera
crean un tipo de versión bioquímica
de un todo que es más mayor que la suma de sus partes?
En este caso, utilizamos el conocido eufemismo, prueba y error
que en realidad no tiene mucho sentido.
Pero si le preguntamos a un indígena, nos contestará: “Las plantas nos lo dijeron".
¿Pero qué significa eso?
Los kofan reconocen hasta 17 variedades de esta liana,
las cuales distinguen a gran distancia en el bosque.
Todas las que nosotros distinguiríamos como solo una especie.
Y les pregunté cómo establecen su taxonomía
y me contestaron: “Pensábamos que sabías algo de plantas".
¿Pero es que no sabes nada? Y yo dije, "No".
Entonces me dijeron que uno toma cada una de las 17 especies
en una noche de luna llena y ellas le cantarán en una melodía distinta.
Eso no te hará obtener un Ph.D. en Harvard,
pero es más interesante que contar estambres.
Pero...
(Aplausos)
el problema... el problema es que hasta nosotros
que entendemos la difícil situación de los pueblos indígenas
los vemos como pintorescos y coloridos
pero, de cierta manera, al margen de la historia,
del mundo real, nuestro mundo, mientras avanzamos.
Bueno, la verdad es que el siglo XX, en 300 años
no se recordará por las guerras
o sus innovaciones tecnológicas
sino como la era en la que contemplamos
y de alguna manera aprobamos o aceptamos de manera pasiva
la destrucción masiva de ambas diversidades tanto biológica como cultural
del planeta. Ahora, el problema no es el cambio.
Con el paso del tiempo,
las culturas cambian constantemente
hacia nuevas posibilidades de vida.
Y el problema no es la tecnología.
Los indios Sioux no dejaron de serlo
cuando dejaron el arco y la flecha
Tampoco los norteamericanos dejaron de serlo
cuando dejaron de utilizar la carreta.
No es el cambio ni la tecnología
lo que amenaza la integridad de la etnosfera. Es el poder.
La cruda cara de la dominación.
Y cuando vemos el mundo alrededor,
descubrimos que estas culturas no están destinadas a desaparecer.
Son pueblos dinámicos
que transitan la existencia por fuerzas identificables
que están más allá de su capacidad de adaptación.
Ya sea una tremenda deforestación
en la tierra de los Penan,
un pueblo nómade del sureste asiático, de Sarawak.
Este pueblo vivió en libertad en el bosque hasta hace una generación
y ahora está reducido a la servidumbre y la prostitución
en los bancos de los ríos,
donde se puede apreciar el río contaminado con el cieno
que parece llevar la mitad de Borneo
al Mar del Sur de China
donde los cargueros japoneses alineados en el horizonte
estaban dispuestos a llenar sus bodegas con leños de la selva.
O en el caso de los yanomami,
son las entidades de las enfermedades que llegaron
a principios del descubrimiento del oro.
O si vamos a las montañas del Tíbet
donde estoy realizando muchas investigaciones recientemente,
veremos que es la cruda cara del dominio político.
Ustedes saben, el genocidio, la extinción física de un pueblo,
está universalmente condenado pero el etnocidio,
la destrucción del estilo de vida de un pueblo, no solo no es condenado universalmente
sino que en muchos lugares es celebrado
como parte de una estrategia de desarrollo.
Y no se entiende el dolor del Tíbet
hasta que uno lo atraviesa por tierra.
Una vez viajé casi 10 000 kilómetros desde Chengdu en China Occidental
por tierra hasta el sureste del Tíbet, hasta Lhasa.
Viajé con un colega joven y fue al llegar a Lhasa
cuando entendí la realidad detrás de las estadísticas
que se comentan.
6000 monumentos sagrados convertidos en polvo y cenizas.
1,2 millones de personas asesinadas por los grupos más poderosos
durante la Revolución Cultural.
El padre de este joven había sido relacionado con el Panchen Lama,
lo que significaba que fue asesinado casi instantáneamente
en el momento de la invasión china.
Su tío había huido con su santidad en la diáspora
que hizo desaparecer al pueblo de Nepal.
Su madre fue encarcelada por
cometer el crimen de ser rica.
Él mismo fue encarcelado de contrabando a la edad de dos años
y se escondía entre las faldas de su madre
porque ella no podía estar sin él.
La hermana quien había realizado esa hazaña
fue recluida en un campo de educación.
Un día, pisó sin querer un brazalete de Mao
y por su trasgresión
fue condenada a siete años de trabajos forzados.
El dolor del Tíbet puede ser casi imposible de soportar
pero el espíritu redentor del pueblo es algo para destacar.
Y al final del mismo, se trata de una simple elección.
¿Deseamos vivir en un mundo monocromático y monótono
o queremos un mundo policromo y diversificado?
La gran antropóloga Margaret Mead dijo antes de morir
que su gran temor era que si nos dejamos llevar hacia
esta cultura única mundial, genérica y amorfa
no solo se reducirá el rango de la imaginación humana
a un modo de pensar estrecho
sino que un día nos despertaríamos, como de un sueño
habiendo olvidado incluso que existieron otras posibilidades.
Y es humilde recordar que nuestra especie
ha existido durante [150 000] años.
La revolución neolítica que nos dio la agricultura,
y que al tiempo nos hizo sucumbir en el culto a la semilla,
desapareció la poesía del chamán
y apareció la prosa del clero,
hemos creado un excedente de especializaciones jerárquicas...
...fue hace solo 10 000 años.
El mundo moderno como lo conocemos
tiene tan solo 300 años de antigüedad
Esta historia superficial no me sugiere
que tenemos todas las respuestas para todos los desafíos
a los que nos enfrentaremos en los próximos milenios.
Cuando preguntamos a esta variedad de culturas del mundo
el significado de ser humano
responden con 10 000 voces diferentes.
Y es con esa actitud que volveremos a descubrir la posibilidad
de ser lo que somos: una especie totalmente consciente
de que debemos proteger todos los pueblos y todos los jardines
para que encuentren una forma de florecer. Y existen grandes momentos de optimismo.
Esta es una fotografía que tomé en la punta norte de la isla Baffin
cuando fui a cazar narvales con varios inuits
y este hombre, Olaya, me contó una maravillosa historia de su abuelo.
El gobierno canadiense no siempre fue considerado con
el pueblo inuit y durante la década de 1950,
con el fin de establecer nuestra soberanía, los obligamos a vivir en asentamientos.
El abuelo de este hombre rehusó a irse.
La familia, que temía por su vida, sacó todas sus armas
y todas sus herramientas.
Deben recordar que los inuits no tienen miedo del frío.
Por el contrario, lo aprovechan.
Originalmente las cubiertas de sus trineos eran de pescado
envueltas en cuero de caribú.
Entonces, el abuelo de mi guía no fue intimidado por la noche ártica
ni la tormenta de nieve que soplaba.
Simplemente se quedó fuera, se bajó los pantalones de piel de foca
y defecó en su mano. Y las heces comenzaron a congelarse.
Les dio forma de cuchillo.
y colocó un poco de saliva al borde del cuchillo de materia fecal
Cuando estuvo sólido por el congelamiento, mató un perro.
Lo desolló e improvisó un arnés,
utilizó las costillas del perro e improvisó un trineo
tirado por otro perro
y desapareció entre los témpanos con el cuchillo de materia fecal en la cintura.
Hablando de subsistir con nada... (Risas)
Y este, en muchas formas,
(Aplausos)
es un símbolo de la resistencia del pueblo inuit
y de todos los pueblos indígenas del mundo.
En abril de 1999, el gobierno de Canadá
devolvió el control total de
un área más grande que California y Texas juntas a los inuits.
Es nuestro nuevo hogar. Se llama Nunavut.
Es un territorio independiente. Ellos controlan los recursos minerales.
Este es un ejemplo excelente de cómo una nación-estado
puede llegar y restituir a su pueblo lo que les pertenece.
Y finalmente, creo que es muy obvio...
al menos para todos los que viajamos
a los confines del planeta
darse cuenta de que estos lugares remotos no lo son en absoluto.
Son el hogar de alguien.
Representan una parte de la imaginación humana
que se remonta al inicio de los tiempos. Y para todos nosotros,
los sueños de estos niños, al igual que los sueños de nuestros propios hijos
forman parte de la geografía viva de la esperanza.
Lo que tratamos finalmente de hacer en National Geographic
es, creemos que los políticos nunca lograrán nada.
Consideramos
(Aplausos)
creemos que la polémica no es persuasiva,
pero creemos que los relatos pueden cambiar el mundo.
Por eso quizás somos la mejor institución contando historias
en el mundo. Hay 35 millones de visitas en nuestro sitio web cada mes.
156 naciones tienen nuestro canal de televisión.
Millones de personas leen nuestras revistas.
Y haremos una serie de viajes
a la etnosfera en los que llevaremos a nuestra audiencia
a lugares con tal belleza cultural
que no podrán evitar quedar deslumbrados
por lo que verán y ojalá que al hacerlo
adquieran gradualmente, uno a uno,
la revelación central de la antropología:
que este mundo merece existir en diversidad
que podemos encontrar una forma de vida
en un mundo verdaderamente multicultural y pluralista
donde toda la sabiduría de los pueblos
pueda contribuir al bienestar de toda la humanidad.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)